avant toute chose je voulais préciser
notre position avant qu'elle soit afin
qu'elle soit claire et sans équivoque un
mort à la chasse et sera toujours un
mort de trop je me suis souvent exprimé
sur cette question vous venez de le
rappeler même les présidents ce sont ces
questions d'insécurité en disant qu'il
fallait toujours être ridicule de
prudence ma vision des choses n'a pas
changé ne pas tirer est aussi un acte de
chasse et nous condamnons tout tir qui
n'est pas fait selon les règles de
sécurité je ne minimise donc en rien
l'importance de la sécurité à la chasse
je souhaiterais néanmoins revenir sur
les circonstances de cette mission
parlementaire en décembre 2021 jeune
homme a été tué dramatiquement dans son
jardin prince chasseurs irresponsable et
un collectif a donc été créé avec un
site un jour un chasseur se il a lancé
mais aussi de cette pétition qui a
recueilli comme vous l'avez dit madame
il présentait bien rappelé plus de cent
mille signatures ce qui nous vaut donc
cette mission si la peine des jolies
filles des jeunes filles qui anime ce
site est réelle et légitime je me et je
m'y associe personnellement d'ailleurs
les intentions les associations qui sont
derrière qui sont derrière le sont pour
moi bien moins elles veulent ni plus ni
moins que la disparition pure et simple
de la chasse on peut d'ailleurs se poser
la question de la représentativité des
associations que vous avez ou que vous
aller auditionner je prendrai l'exemple
par exemple de ce monsieur vallençant
que vous avez récemment accueilli et qui
est le président d'une puissante
association de 292 personnes
alors qu'il ya d'ailleurs une fédération
nationale de la montagne et de
l'escaladé qui elle n'a pas été invitée
évidemment nous n'avons pas été épargnés
par ces propos on s'en doutait on
connaît mais d'autres devraient suivre
dans la même lignée et je pense que par
exemple aux groupuscules havas dont les
actions musclées contre les activités
légales sont déjà ont désormais reconnu
comme légitime
au sein de la haute assemblée par le
simple fait de leur invitation à
participer à ce débat
nous sommes donc présents ce soir par la
volonté d'une association qui récolte à
travers la france les milliers
d'incivilités dans se rendre responsable
les chasseurs ce site en ligne peut
donner froid dans le dos quand à
quiconque souhaiterait prendre la nature
comme un espace libre de promenade est
en moi mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je veux dois me peau de poser
plus qu'une limite aux contenus détenu
par cette association en effet
rapidement nous avons remarqué que les
histoires qui commençait à s'étaler sur
la toile des réseaux sociaux à travers
ce site
concernant l'attitude dangereuse du
monde cynégétique avec l'homme qui
viennent un petit air répétitif dans la
narration
c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé apporté
une large contribution personnelle dans
la collecte de ces histoires rurales
afin d'amener plus de diversité dans les
exactions des chasseurs nous avons été
surpris d'ailleurs de la facilité à
déverser des contenus haineux est
totalement mensonger à lier de l'achat
de la chasse sur ce sur ce site
la seule chose qu'on nous a demandé
d'ailleurs de façon explicite c'est
systématiquement d'enrichir le contenu
de nos propos par quelques détails
croustillants on peut imaginer pour
donner une force médiatique plus
importante à nos petites légendes rural
lors bien sûr en notre possession tout
ce qu'il faut pour étayer la véracité de
mes propos madame la présidente
nous revenons bien sûr à la sécurité qui
est un sujet de préoccupation permanente
des fédérations des chasseurs et qui
n'ont pas attendu un jour un chasseur
pour se saisir de cette question j'en
veux pour preuve la baisse constante des
accidents de chasse en me basant sur les
chiffres de de l'oncf et speedo et mais
j'imagine que vous avez évoqué ce sujet
directement et pierre dubreuil il y à
quelques instants mais c'est toujours
bon rappeler effectivement à 6 ans 20
ans ni via une diminution de 65 % des
accidents de chasse en général et
surtout une baisse de 4 22 % des
accidents mortels dans le même temps
les tableaux de chasse de granby ont
augmenté de 75 % et le nombre de balles
tirées par les uns briller 2 66%
contrairement à ce que certains croient
l'année 2020 2021 n'a pas connu malgré
la crise sanitaire une diminution des
activités en mesure de chasse puisque là
encore les tableaux de chasse grand
gibier 2020-2021 sont identiques à ceux
des années précédentes
à chaque accident une enquête est
diligentée par la gendarmerie avec lots
élevés dans la quasi totalité des cas
les accidents sont dus à un non respect
des mesures de sécurité en vigueur
encore une fois sans minimiser les faits
je vous engage à lire l'étude de santé
publique france sur les décès
traumatique en pratique sportive en
france métropolitaine en 2017 2018 car
même si les accidents mortels de chasse
était élevé et au nombre de 34 pour ces
deux années
la chasse est bien loin en terme de
statistiques de certaines pratiques
sportives ou de loisirs et contrairement
à ce que j'entends régulièrement une
pratique port sportive quelle qu'elle
soit pratiquée dans un cadre sécuritaire
peut s'avérer dramatique pour autrui une
paire de skis peut être aussi une arme
mortelle comme l'actualité récente vient
encore de nous le prouver à partir de là
de nombreuses activités de plein air
finiront par subir les mêmes attaques en
finissant par l'interdiction de conduire
un véhicule qui devient à partir de ce
raisonnement loti pratique statisme ans
le statistiquement pendant le plus
dangereux qui soit d'ailleurs si la
chasse était si accidentogènes que
veulent bien le dire les anti-chasse
létard et les assurance responsabilité
civile pour l'achat serait bien plus
élevé que ça mais je pense que les
propos tenus ici là quelques jours par
un assureur sur le risque de collision
liés aux animaux sauvages ont été
exposées de façon suffisamment
explicites pour ne pas revenir à nouveau
dessus
à part la solution émanant des grands
sachant de l'écologie parfaite où nous
aurions dans l'avenir plus de 10000
louer de 5000 course en liberté sur le
territoire national pour réguler
l'ensemble des trois animaux sauvages
complexifier la pratique de la chasse ou
même la supprimer d'ailleurs devra
entraîner chaque année la mort de
plusieurs centaines de nos concitoyens
non chasseurs dans des collisions
routières sans oublier le retour nation
de la prédation naturelle sur l'espèce
humaine par ces grands prédateurs
dams et messieurs les chiffres ne pas
mentir et ils montrent que herman une
forte diminution une diminution
constante des accidents liés à la chasse
et c'est la tradition en direct des
efforts faits en matière de sécurité par
les chasseurs eux-mêmes
la chasse est particulièrement
réglementée et les mesures de sécurité
existent et sont nombreuses en rajouter
ne changerait rien ce qu'il faut c'est
poursuivre le travail de formation de
nos chasseurs comme le font actuellement
nos fédérations et savoir prendre des
sanctions exemplaires en cas de non
respect des règles élémentaires de
sécurité mesdames et messieurs si vous
regardez bien les derniers accidents qui
se sont produits à chaque fois il s'agit
principalement d'un non respect des
règles règlementaire de sécurité de la
part des chasseurs mais parfois aussi un
enchaînement d'interaction qui aurait
plus de la malchance que de la faute
grave en fonction des départements selon
le biotope et le mode de chasse
pratiquée
certaines mesures peuvent compléter les
règles générales de sécurité dans les
schémas départementaux de gestion
cynégétique je tiens d'ailleurs attirer
votre attention sur le fait que la
vérité d'un territoire même d'un
département n'est pas forcément valable
est applicable chez le voisin du fait de
ces biotopes de l'organisation de la
chasse elle même de la superficie
couverte ou simplement des modes de
chasse pratiquée les schémas
départementaux de gestion cynégétique
sont justement là pour fixer des règles
sécuritaires adaptée au contexte local
vous avez auditionné différentes
associations qui chassent dans les
semaines qui viennent et j'attire votre
attention sur le risque d'une dérive
similaire au lancement d'un nouveau
concours lépine de la meilleure
disposition à prendre contre la chasse
il est d'ailleurs déjà très ouverts nous
l'avons entendu avec l'audition du
général le gendarmerie 8 minet qui veut
classer les armes de chasse en catégorie
mais comme vous le savez tous le
terrorisme et de violence urbaine ne
sont nullement lié à la détention
d'armes de chasse nos adversaires
cherchent à dire le contraire nous
pourrions en rire si n'ajoutez pas à
l'obscénité
président n'ajoutez pas l'obscénité 20
ans à la mauvaise foi en rajoutant dans
ses dérives les féminicides lié d'après
eux au cerveau reptilien du chasseur
c'est ce qu'on entend maintenant
régulièrement partout
sacha est une pratique légale et
populaires issues des premières heures
de la révolution française et elle
incarne le concept même de la liberté
individuelle à la française avec je vous
la corde les imperfections naturelle
liée à toutes les pratiques de l'espèce
humaine oui nous ne sommes pas des
robots personne dans ce pays ne souhaite
le viread ailleurs mais le risque zéro
n'existe pas la chasse comme dans toutes
nos actions puissiez vous madame des
messieurs garder en tête cette vérité
avant de nous soumettre par exemple au
principe de la balise argos individuelle
tant souhaitées par nos ennemis si la
chasse est déjà très encadrée dans son
volet sécuritaire elle bouge et s'adapte
sans cesse avec la modernité son temps
mais on oublie un peu vite quentin en
chasseur perd la vie statistiquement
d'ailleurs un tous les deux ans pour
être précis c'est pourquoi nous
cherchons systématiquement affiné sans
cesse la sécurité dans nos pratiques
ainsi à me demandent trois règles
nationales sont en vigueur depuis la loi
du 24 juillet 2019 pour augmenter la
sécurité
la généralisation du port d'un vêtement
fluorescents pour les chasses collective
de façon à être vu aussi bien par les
chasseurs eux mêmes mais également par
les autres usagers de la nature les
chasseurs n'avaient pas attendu cette
obligation de très nombreux départements
avait déjà exigé le exiger le port d'un
dispositif fut nommé certains considérer
qu'une casquette ou qu'un bras ou un
brassard pouvais te le pouvaient suffire
nous avons souhaité harmoniser
l'ensemble de ces mesures toute chasse
collective est obligatoirement signalés
par des panneaux sur l'accotement ou à
proximité immédiate des voies publiques
pour matérialiser les entrées
principales de la zone de chasse
ceci permet une information locale et
précise au moment même de l'action de
chasse d'ailleurs il devient urgent de
punir sévèrement les personnes qui
s'emploie régulièrement au vol
systématique de ces panneaux de sécurité
pourtant essentiel dans certains
territoires périurbains au fortement
fréquenté le week-end enfin arrivant à
la tête de la fnc en 2007 j'ai moi même
proposé que soit mise en place une
remise à niveau en matière de sécurité
pour chaque chasseur tous les dix ans
connaissez vous une âme des messieurs un
seul port de loisirs qui est mis en
place
sa propre initiative une telle chose
aucun pensez vous pensez cette remise à
niveau n'existe même pas pour le permis
de conduire doit je vous le rappeler
chaque chasseur est convoqué on une demi
journée durant laquelle on lui présente
des situations d'accidents de chasse
réel afin qu'ils prennent conscience que
l'accident n'arrive pas qu'aux autres
comme je l'avais écrit à deux ans à 3
maintenant d'ailleurs ces règles lui
sont répétés martelé expliciter la crise
sanitaire a malheureusement retardé la
mise en place de ces formations et nous
avons un million de pratiquants a
convoqué nous avons débuté en mai 2021
dans quelques fédérations pilotes cela
se déploie depuis de façon générale
depuis mois septembre à ce jour près de
vingt mille chasseurs ont déjà suivi
cette remise à niveau sur une année
complète
cela représente une trentaine de tp
mobilisés pour ces remises à niveau et
uniquement sur nos fonds propres puisque
cette formation demeure gratuite comme
nous l'avons souhaité
comme prévu également par la loi de 2019
les fédérations des chasseurs ont mis en
place au sein de leurs instances des
commissions sécurité afin d'élaborer des
mesures de prévention mais aussi des
sanctions à l'égard de chasseurs au
comportement dangereux c'est une mesure
que j'ai souhaité et qui permet de
sanctionner durablement les personnes
ayant un comportement accidentogène
répétitifs sans besoin pour autant
d'apprendre que l'irrémédiable se
produise les sanctions peuvent aller
jusqu'à demander au préfet de retirer le
permis de aux chasseurs concernée de
façon générale et contrairement à ce que
l'on entend trop souvent il n'ya aucun
compromis avec la sécurité de notre part
et aucun accident n'est étoffé par le
monde de la chasse mais les fédérations
des chasseurs n'avaient pas attendu ces
nouvelles lois pour agir depuis de très
nombreuses années c'est important de
rappeler tout ça les fédérations ont mis
en place des formations à la sécurité
pour les organisateurs de chasse pour
les chefs de battue pour les chefs de
ligne pour la manipulation des armes en
moyenne ces 27 mille responsables
d'organisations de chasse qui suivent
ces formations chaque année là encore
c'est un investissement d'une vingtaine
de salariés au sein des fédérations et
ces formations vont perdurer même avec
la mise en place de cette formation
décennale qui va vraiment pouvoir
commencer avec cette année 2022 en
matière de prévention les fédérations
sont aussi très actif 92% d'entre elles
proposent aux chasseurs des subventions
pour installer quand cela est possible
bien sûr des miradors sur le territoire
ce qui permet de garantir un tir plus
fichant
elle distribue des posters des fiches de
consignes de sécurité remettre dans les
cabanes de chasse et à distribuer aux
chasseurs il faut bien comprendre que
toute journée de chasse débute pas ce
qu'on appelle le rond le rang de chasse
je sais que certains d'entre vous s'y
sont rendus récemment le responsable de
la chasse rassemble tout le monde
explique le déroulé de la journée
rappelle les consignes de sécurité en
précisant tous les cas particuliers 6h
main si un chemin ouvert au public
traverse le territoire où une ferme
isolée dans un coin et ces mêmes
consignes personnalisés sont encore
répété quand le chasseur arrive à son
poste deux battus on pourrait dire que
c'est la meilleure formation continue de
pratiquants et nous le faisons toutes
les semaines au titre de la pédagogie
plus d'un tiers des fédérations mise en
oeuvre avec les parcs et des stages
sensibilisation des auteurs
d'infractions de chasse ce qui donne
l'occasion à ces personnes de passer une
journée complète consacrée aux règles de
sécurité vis-à-vis des chasseurs mais
surtout des tiers vous devez aussi ça va
avoir à l'esprit qu'une trentaine de
fédérations recruter des agents de
développement assermentés et que ce sont
aujourd'hui acteurs professionnels de
premier plan en matière de surveillance
de prévention et de médiation
l'évolution des missions des inspecteurs
de l'environnement de la mb démontrent
que ces quelques 200 agents de
développement sont désormais souvent
tout seul en première ligne sur le
terrain pour éduquer le chasseur mis
surtout veiller au respect des règles de
sécurité or à la chasse comme en toutes
matières la peur du gendarme est bien
réelle il faut mettre en place une
véritable police de proximité à vocation
cynégétique entre premier lieu la
proposition que j'avais fait au moment
du salon des maires a été brocardée mais
c'est pourtant le correspond
parfaitement un peu - de sécuritaire
croissant sur le terrain nous manquons
cruellement de police de chasse mesdames
et messieurs et je suis sûr que certains
accidents auraient pu être évitées par
plus de contrôle et par peur du passage
de l'agent fédéral
le moma le passé de certains de dire
qu'on a plus de chances de gagner au
loto que d'être contrôlé par la police
de la chasse mais parfois ça ressemble à
ça quand même malheureusement même si
cela est largement exagéré je vous la
corde il est néanmoins évident que
l'absence de police de l'absence de
police n'est le danger d'un laxisme
sécuritaire c'est une énigme une
évidence alors plutôt que de nous
retirer nos prérogatives en matière de
police de chasse
fait par les agents de fédération des
chasseurs comme vous les avez l'avait
fait fin vous d'autres mais mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs par un
amendement lors de la loi chasse de
juillet 2019 j'espère que vous pourrez
corriger cette erreur majeure tout en
pensant au financement qui va bien sûr
avec enfin sujet primordial dans ce qui
nous intéresse aujourd'hui la
cohabitation sur les espaces ruraux
il faut parler de cohabitation et non de
partage la nature carli de notre
responsabilité collective de nous
entendre dans le respect des uns et des
autres nous n'avons pas attendu les
pouvoirs publics pour engager un
dialogue de vérité avec un certain
nombre de fédérations de sports de
loisirs et de sports et loisirs que je
vais saluer ici car elles ont eu tout le
courage de dépasser les préjugés pour
échanger et construire avec nous
aujourd'hui de nombreuses fédérations de
chasseurs ont signé des conventions avec
les usagers pet est ici glisse cavaliers
randonneurs et j'en passe la fnc est mis
en place avec la fédération française
d'équitation la fédération française de
cyclotourisme la fédération française de
randonnée la mountain bike la fondation
de la fédération française de course
d'orientation
un panneau d'information chasse en cours
à destination des usagers non chasseurs
afin de les informer sur le comportement
à avoir lorsqu'il croise des chasseurs
où se retrouvent au sein d'un territoire
de chasse ce panneau avec un qr code
d'ailleurs permis une information
détaillée des échanges d'informations
telles que calandri une manifestation
d'un thé modalités de chasse dans
certains secteurs
ont lieu à l'est sont départementales
les associations sportives et de loisirs
et les fédérations des chasseurs
encouragent leurs adhérents à
communiquer entre eux à l'échelon des
communes il n'y a pas particulièrement
difficultés entre licenciés de ces clubs
sportifs ou de loisirs et les chasseurs
néanmoins et je vous l'accordé il faut
toujours distinguer le licencié qui est
souvent destinataire d'information qui
est organisée équipe est souvent de
vêtements de couleur vit d'ailleurs
parce qu'ils connaissent et règles
laïques simple il sait très bien comment
les choses se pratique et le simple
promeneur qui n'est adhérents d'aucune
association fédération et part en toute
liberté dans la nature sans se
renseigner parfois sans comprendre ce
qui se passe au niveau de la chasse en
cours autour de lui c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut un partenariat
permanent à l'échelle départementale
entre les différentes fédérations des
usagers de la nature afin de conduire
des actions d'information à la fois vis
dans 10 des licenciés et plus largement
des pratiquants au niveau national nous
avons donc créé l'alliance des sports et
loisirs de nature on y retrouve la
chasse forcément la pêche le vdt
l'équitation le golf la montagne et
escalade la plaisance la pêche en mer et
même la pétanque
hélas cette information n'est pas
toujours connus et le self et d'entendre
des coups de feu peu découragé des
promeneurs alors qu'une grande partie de
la commune concernée est accessible en
même temps il faut aussi rappeler à ses
usagers que eux aussi doivent respecter
les consignes et les panneaux on voit
encore des promeneurs en contenant forêt
domaniale au coeur même de la traque
malgré un panneau d'interdiction de
l'eau nf
rappelons aussi que 75 % de la forêt
française est privé et que le promeneur
ne devrait normalement pas y pénétrer
pendant une chasse sauf bien sûr s'il
reste sur les chemins communaux autorisé
leur propriété si chère aux valeurs de
cette assemblée me paraît essentiel dans
la proche sécuritaire de la chasse en
général disposer d'un cadre particulier
pour le domaine public comme c'est déjà
aujourd'hui le cas me paraît acceptable
mais ailleurs la liberté doit prévaloir
quand on pratique chez soi sa passion et
que celle ci est une activité
respectable et potentiellement
accessibles lire man aux quelques 4,5
millions de personnes qui possèdent un
permis de chasse et qu'en france je vous
remercie
merci monsieur président juste quelques
propos avant de laisser la parole à un
autre rapporteur rappeler que notre
mission n'a pas vocation à rentrer dans
le débat pour ou contre la chasse
mais on reste avec notre rapporteur
quand bessonneau sur notre ligne et
uniquement celle là de parler de la
sécurisation de cette pratique dont nous
ne rentrerons pas dans ce débat et
comptez sur nous pour rester sur cette
ligne tout en étant aussi m 2 qui on
souhaite entendre qu' on souhaite
recevoir il nous a pas échappé les
échanges violents et haineux sur la
toile et les mails qu'on reçoit aussi au
quotidien même si cela semble beaucoup
plus
adoucies mais nous souhaitons travailler
dans la sérénité et la neutralité la
plus totale donc vous pouvez être
confiants sur nos capacités à nous faire
une idée aussi ne pas donner crédit non
plus à tous les propos excessifs voilà
c'est ce que je souhaitais rajouter
avant de passer la parole à notre notre
rapporteur pour quelques questions et
des échanges sans filtre comme nous
avions décidé dès le début de la mission
de procéder sur son autre méthode merci
madame la présidente merci de ce rappel
j'avais effectivement vous dire monsieur
le président en préambule fait confiance
parlementaire de cette mission qui donc
auront évidemment donc dans leur analyse
je pense
la distance nécessaire en tout cas la
neutralité nécessaire pour entendre et
juger l'ensemble des propos alors par
rapport à votre
propos liminaire
j'aurai une première question qui
concerne l'un des schémas départementaux
de gestion cynégétique vous l'avez vous
avez abordé en disant qu' il réglait un
certain nombre de problèmes et je le
crois bien volontiers
néanmoins donc l'observation que qu'est
la nôtre à ce stade c'est que leur
nombre leur diversité et aussi donc
assez
hétérogène sur
l'ensemble du territoire national donc
comment une fois quel regard avez-vous
justement par rapport à ces schémas
départementaux et est allé vite que
peut-on faire pour faire en sorte qu' on
est une amélioration de ses schémas
départementaux voir une
homogénéisation
écoutez monsieur le rapporteur les
schémas départementaux correspondent au
besoin je dirais du département concerné
donc je je l'avais dit dans mes propos
liminaire moi je ne partage pas du tout
le fait de niveler effectivement
l'ensemble des mesures elles peuvent
être concret dans un département est
complètement illusoire dans un autre je
pense qu'au contraire ils vont au
suffisamment loin il y à des parties de
sécurité à remplir ils sont remplis
voilà je pense que l'on s'adapte on
s'adapte parfaitement aux choses que
vous avez d'été appartement chasse en
france qui chassent beaucoup de grands
gibiers des fois même pas du tout le
petit d'autres qui sont des départements
de chasse de petit gibier d'autres de
gibier d'eau migrateurs ou gibier d'eau
voilà on a cet outil qu'est met à
disposition je pense qu'il est
parfaitement bien utilisé j'en suis même
persuadé dois je vous rappeler les
toujours la même chose ces chiffres qui
sont toujours en baisse drastique ça
n'arrête pas de baisser et nous nous
battons sans cesse pour faire diminuer
donc les outils on les a pour les outils
on les a il reste un pourcentage faible
assise d'accidents que je rappelle et
d'une personne malheureusement non
chasseurs parents tous les deux ans qui
peut perdre la vie c'est toujours trop
mais on est passé quand même d'une
situation il ya cinquante ans on était
au delà de 50 morts alors qu'il y avait
deux fois moins grand gibier le 3 from
un grand gibier en france donc à partir
de là le travail est fait les schémas
sont très bien fait et on utilise tout
ce qu'il faut utiliser dans ses schémas
est on est on les fait vivre sans cesse
on les corrigeons les amendes on discute
avec les préfets et on discute avec les
autres usagers de la nature au niveau
local il ya c'est ce sont des choses qui
sont en totale évolution permanente et
la chasse reste dans la modernité de son
temps mais voilà à partir de là moi je
pense qu'on a tous les outils il peut y
avoir des accidents ont les déplore on
les sanctionne donc je reviens petit peu
ce que je disais tout à l'heure je je
regrette qu'on ait effectivement perdu
les prérogatives de police de chasser ça
je pense que c'est un vrai argument
parce que comme sur la route la peur du
gendarme c'est la peur du gendarme si
vous savez vous serez jamais contrôlé
bâtisse est limitée à 130 vous le leur à
200 vous savez qui se passera rien on y
reviendra dessus
oui oui vous rappeler de façon générale
les outils existent ils sont là les
questions sur notamment le maintenant le
permis de chasse vous avez un chiffre
donc de nombre de chasseurs est ce que
nous confirmait le nombre de chasseurs
qui dispose d'un permis
sans avoir passé l'examen
et donc je veux combien d'examen donc
alors au par opposition c'est un chiffre
qui est difficile pour nous retrouver
pour le dire honnêtement par contre je
regarde effectivement qui provoque les
accidents parce que je vois dans votre
question ce que voulait dire on dirait
effectivement que tous les vieux ne
seraient plus aptes à l'achat non c'est
pas du tout mon propos je chante en
jeu
notre démarche elle est de se renseigner
de pouvoir récolter des informations
sans avoir absolument aucun a priori en
tout cas je peux vous dire que je suis
parti il pas présidente faut dire
simplement que quand on regarde alors
certes un peu des recomptages j'en suis
très étonné parce que nous regardons
précisément l'âge des gens qui
provoquent la pratique aux accidents
évidemment qui a pas d'âge il n'y a pas
d'âge on peut pas dire que les gens de
plus de x années enfin puisque le permis
de chasser est arrivé en
75 je crois que forcément les gens avant
75 serait qui annuleront eu leur permis
de chasser avant 75 seraient des gens
qui soient plus dangereux que les autres
rien rien effective linguistique ne peut
dire ce genre de confiance et on a même
eu un vainqueur exceptionnelle qui
m'avait beaucoup marqué je crois que
s'il ya trois ans on a un gamin qui
sortait du permis de chasser qu'il avait
depuis six mois et qui a fait une erreur
mais monumental alors quand on s'est
bien vite difficile de passer un permis
de chasse et maintenant est bon c'est
l'incompréhension totale comme quoi
effectivement qui voilà tout être humain
peut des fois faire une erreur une
fraction de seconde on en fit tous tous
les jours des fois ça se fasse et une
fois sur x froid vous avez la
catastrophe dont l'âge ne fit rien à
faire et le fait ne pas avoir passé des
examens pratiques n'est pas n'est pas
significatif d'ailleurs de toute façon
vous le savez monsieur le rapporteur à
partir de cette année tout le monde va
être formé tout le monde donc il ya des
gens effectivement quinon qui n'ont pas
passé l'examen pratique de permis de
chasse et j'en fais partie je fais
partie de ces gens qui ont coché des
cases en théorie sur 21 une réponse il
en fallait cependant un permis de
chasser mais tout le monde est effective
devra effectivement aux renault aura
cette remise à niveau d'un point de vue
sécuritaire et bien sûr dans cette
remise à niveau c'est la sécurité qui
prime par dessus tout et c'est ça que
nous allons travailler à et je le disais
tout à l'heure des ronds l'a fait de
notre propre chef j'ai fait entre
guillemets campagne pour l'élection 2016
à la tête de la fnc en passant par tous
et en disant aux gens si vous votez pour
moi je vous préviens tout de suite vous
allez tous avoir une remise à niveau
sécuritaire à frères tous les dix ans
pour composer les choses étaient très
claires de ce côté
alors peut-être pouvez-vous me dire à
quelle est votre analyse analyse de
votre fédération sur les accidents et
les incidents de chasse une façon donc
très générale vous n'avez pas exprimée
dans votre luminaire mais de façon
peut-être alors on ne peut plus les
accidents on vient d'en parlé plusieurs
fois ils sont en baisse on est ainsi
dans une voie là alors les incidents il
faudrait en fait beaucoup plus je vais
très mesuré je le disais tout à l'heure
pour ce site un jour un chasseur on a
mis ce qu'on vous les dents et quand
c'était pas si violent nous a demandé
des théiers donc on est un peu le truc
donc à partir de là soyons prudents sur
les incidents parce que c'est facile de
raconter quelque chose sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est facile de créer des sites
où il ya des gens qui voient des
atrocités du côté du monde de la chasse
sauf que nous sur le terrain quand on
discute avec les gens on les trouve pas
ces gens là alors je dis pas qu'il n'y a
pas quelques chasseurs qui se conduisent
mal bien évidemment si vous prenez 10
personnes dans la société d'aujourd'hui
10 chasseurs ou dix autres personnes il
y aura toujours un pourcentage de gens
qui peuvent faire des erreurs ou qui
peuvent se conduire de façon je dirais
très désagréable que les gens aient
provoqué un incident comme vous dites au
vert pâle ou même peut-être au physique
j'en sais rien
moi je vois quand même que dans nos
communes on discute avec les gens là où
les gens vivent ensemble et se
connaissent et se connaissent tous très
bien d'ailleurs c'est plutôt un échange
j'irai convivial sur sur sur la pratique
de la chasse donc je ne sais pas d'où
sort c'est un petit peu dans l'air du
temps c'est le rapporteur on voit bien
aujourd'hui tout ça c'est quand même
très médiatisée il ya beaucoup
d'orientation donc on a comme ça
maintenant tous ces gens spontanément
qui racontent des horreurs effectivement
dans la pratique de la chasse
franchement franchement à titre
personnel je n'y crois pas la preuve est
temps qu'on en a injecté au temps comme
on a voulu sur ces sites et on pourra
vous donner tous les documents qui le
prouvent
alors vous allez
mesures à mettre en oeuvre
selon vous sur quels
secteurs
doit-on encore progresser pour améliorer
la sécurité écoutez avec la nouvelle
formation décennale moi je pense que
c'était peut-être le dernier outil qui
nous manque les pour aller plus loin je
le redis une seule rapporteur et c'est
vrai que l'on va on va peut-être se
répéter où je suis chez moi me répéter
c'est pas grave mais c'est pas grave on
a on aurait eu on aurait une courbe à la
hausse qu'on remet quand même juste bien
le cadre aux multiples on augmente de 75
points de 2 75% les prélèvements de
grand gibier c'est pas rien quand même
donc on parle même pas du nombre de
chasseurs puisque on voit bien que les
le côté le côté accident à harry
beaucoup dans la chasse du grand gibier
donc on a de plus en plus de grands
gibiers ça explose littéralement à une
époque on avait cinquante morts y ont
tué 40 me sens bien en france on en
apprenait pratiquement aux millions donc
il faut bien les tirs avaient quelque
chose avec des balles avec des carabines
on est bien tous d'accord là dessus et
on ne fait que baisser mais de façon
plus que significative donc faut bien
comprendre que le travail de fond est
fait par les fédérations départementales
et la fédération nationale n'y a aucun
problème que chef chasseurs prend
conscience qui est même une auto censure
interne qui se développe comme je
l'avais demandé encore dans dans dans ce
que j'avais écrit il manquait peut-être
cette formation décennale pas que je
pense effectivement que les gens qui ont
eu un permis en 75 étaient plus
responsables que les autres mais et le
petit refrain revient régulièrement donc
nous allons repasser régulièrement toute
personne avec un oeil observateurs si
jamais nous avions des doutes sur des
personnes qu'ils montraient pourrait
nous montrent effectivement certaines su
gérer certains gestes ou certaine
méconnaissance effectivement de de la
pratique de certaines chasses on
pourrait tout à fait leur demander
d'approfondir les choses on a cette
possibilité
donc voila moi je pense que c'était le
dernier outil avec celui là je dirais
monsieur le rapporteur mon but il est
simple avoir un nombre de d'accidents
mortels qui se rapprochent quasiment de
zéro dans les années qui viennent et je
pense qu'on a tous les outils déjà dans
les mains pour le faire nous avons le
même objectif
donc c'est parfait ce côté là donc vous
évoquiez donc la formation
complémentaire donc vous mettez en place
aujourd'hui combien de deux chasseurs
ont suivi cette formation et à quelle
échéance vous pensé justement que tout
le monde aura suivi cette formation
alors on passe un million de personnes 1
million de pratiquants chaque année
quatre millions de personnes détiennent
a permis de chasser avec un turnover
avec des gens qui arrêtent pour raisons
professionnelles une année cinq années
aux raisons familiales qui reviennent
sur pac man on va passer effectivement
tous et où tous ces gens dans ce délai
de dix années voilà le but est entre
d'ailleurs d'être un petit peu plus vite
nous souhaitons accélérer un peu les
choses qu'on a mis dix ans et dans le
fond on a bien fait qu'on ne commence
tout il part 2 android comment réunir
des gens dans des petites réunions dans
des endroits fermés ou même en extérieur
c'était compliqué donc pour l'instant on
a un bilan plutôt positif
un bon retour les gens les chasseurs
d'ailleurs même jour lui on n'a passé
que vingt mille personnes ce qui est
dérisoire pour nous mais on sera
probablement
aller à je dirais à 150000 à la fin de
l'année donc on va avancer très vite et
après ça va se roder ça valait beaucoup
beaucoup plus vite c'est très bien
accueillie par le monde de la chasse
personne ne s'est plaint de ses plans de
ça au contraire les gens trouvent que
c'est bien qu'on vienne leur parler de
sécurité qu'on vérifie des choses et
qu'on qu'on leur demande avec le
formateur de revivre effectivement les
le mans terre comment calcule un angle
de 30 degrés même si ca devien scolaire
et répétitif c'est pas grave on a
beaucoup de salies pour la sécurité on
passera le temps qu'il faut donc donc on
a quand même aventure à la fois positive
du monde cynégétique et les premiers
gens qui ont passé ces formations dont
je fais partie d'ailleurs on a les
images choc on joue le jeu j'avais comme
pour la sécurité routière vous montez
des accidents dans les publicités à la
télévision quand on montre à plusieurs
reprises les faits qu'à une balle sur un
corps humain je peux vous dire que les
gens réfléchissent en sortant dont je
suis sûr que que cette formation
décennale va encore effectivement tendre
à diminuer le nombre d'accidents général
vous avez évoqué propos liminaire donc
la notion de balises qui vous serez
coller
la balise argos
comment voyez-vous et éventuellement
justement l'apport de la technologie
sur l'aide à la sécurité alors
nous ne sommes pas contre la technologie
est pas le problème on a un contexte
particulier à certains endroits ça se
passera toujours bien je vais prendre
ici la grande couronne parisienne il
suffit de géolocaliser les chasse pour
se retrouver qu'un comité d'accueil à
chaque fois qu on ressortira avec une
carabine un chien ou quoi que ce soit ça
c'est un énorme problème
je reviens sur ce groupuscule avec vous
allez recevoir qui est quand même assez
particulier dans l' entrave à la chasse
déjà des gens qui recherchent toute la
semaine où ça va se passer alors si en
plus on le met carrément sur internet
maintenant alors la partie où ils ont
une application dans la poche pour
savoir où notre rendre voyez c'est pas
si simple que ça s'est passé ça me fait
pas forcément donc ce type d'outil
qu'elle pensait mais quelque part c'est
un peu ça s'est effectué en mai par
exemple l'outil
de vérification de vente de 32 et par
exemple qui pourrait donc être un outil
qui n'existe pas mais qui pourrait
coûter langue de 32 ans n'a pas besoin
grand tout ici à droite 3 pas devant
vous le dire à des gens qui a envie de
vendre des outils on a tout proposé ça
coûte 10 euros 50 euros 200 euros 500
euros il y en a même un qui nous
introduisent un 1500 la carabine vivre
et quand vous étiez aux aidants langue
de 30 degrés dans l on peut tout
imaginer il ya quand même un truc tout
simple et les gens le savent bien
maintenant et ça rentre vraiment dans
les moeurs ces 5 passes et 3 pas vous
mettez un jalon qui est souvent
d'ailleurs un bout de bois dans la forêt
c'est ce qui est plus facile il souvent
d'ailleurs on a un petit peu de un petit
peu de trucs l'aurait censure nous ont
eu au bout du bâton des choses comme ça
pour ceux qui voient pas bien le les
choses on n'a pas besoin de grandes
technologies dans le fond de la forêt
pour marquer les angles de 30 degrés et
puis ça vient et puis je vais vous dire
monsieur le rapporteur les angles de 30
degrés moi je comprends le le problème
ac2 le problème en ville envers les
accidents savez je fais partie de ces
gens qui n'ont pas passé effectivement
d'examen pratique bon j'ai beaucoup
pratiqué donc ça va mais quand on
commence à poser les jalons et même pour
moi et qu'on recalcule 7 32 30 degrés
réellement on est surpris des fois de la
petitesse de langue et du et des langues
qui reste pour tirer
donc tout ça c'est du passé on voit
maintenant cette prise de conscience
elle est collective
moi j'ai pas besoin d'acheter un outil à
rayons laser pour calculer l'ordre de 30
de vos posts je pense que ce serait pas
ce serait déraisonnable par rapport je
dirais à ce que ça va représenter
réapprenons bien les cinq pas les trois
pas dans les formations décennale
faisons répéter ça en cadence dans la
salle et on aura beaucoup plus de
résultats toute technologie dans ce
domaine
très bien
en matière donc le d'accident est ce que
votre fédération s'est déjà donc
constituer partie civile ou à porter
plainte pour accident alors la fnc ne
peut pas le faire bien 20 c'est la
fédération départementale voilà donc il
ya des commissions effectivement de
sécurité mais il ya aussi des
commissions de police dans chaque
fédération ou les fédérations se
réunissent et très effectivement tous
les pv qui ont été mis voire même dans
des cas exceptionnels heureusement un
accident mortel ou non mortels
d'ailleurs nous le mot d'ordre est
simple c'est évidemment le parties
civiles systématiquement c'est ce que
nous demandons aux fédérations des
partout
sur la prise en charge des victimes et
sur la question d'assurance que vous
avez évoquées en disant finalement
l'assurance n'était pas aussi élevé que
que cela et si jamais il y avait un
risque donc avéré ça pourrait être le
cas
que pensez-vous de la prise en charge
des victimes ou d'ailleurs des familles
des victimes qui a amélioré donc c'est
cette prise en charge
dit autrement à ce que le champ de
l'assurance chasse obligatoires
doit-elle d'hôtes il est très étendue
écoutez je vois pas étendu dans quelle
direction actuelle à la prise en charge
justement des victimes et familles en
haïti quand effectivement il ya un
accident avec une personne qui est qui
est assuré et surtout aux lettres est
assurée passe au tribunal
voyez la justice ce que demande la
justice effectivement à la personne qui
a commis un accident pour prendre
l'exemple de mortel a toujours été
couverts par les assurances donc je vois
pas bien quel champ augmenter puisque ce
que les gens demandent devant un
tribunal correspond à la loi et
l'obtiennent donc l'assurance paye j'ai
jamais entendu parler d'une assurance
qui refusait de payer quelqu'un qui est
assurée qui avait causé un accident tout
est réglé voilà en fonction
effectivement du cadre de la loi donc je
vois pas trop l'extrême quoi nous
servirait l'extension d'assurance
puisque les gens obtiennent au tribunal
à juste titre d'ailleurs attention s'est
produit tout à juste titre ils
obtiennent effectivement ce que la
justice se demande donc voilà dans le
cadre de la loi et les assurances paye
nous n'avons pas à ma connaissance je
n'ai jamais entendu parler d'un cas de
figure où l'assurance a refusé de payer
en estimant que le contrat d'assurance
était insuffisant par rapport aux
fectivement ce qui avait pu décider le
tribunal et le juge donc c'est que je
j'imagine que d'un point de bien sûr ans
tout est couvert correctement contre
dédommagement de la famille d'une
victime
merci vous l'avez déjà aussi un peu
abordée mais je souhaiterais que vous
répondiez précisément à la question des
randonnées en moins c'est sur les
méthodes de chasse et ce qui semble
nécessaire de faire évoluer les méthodes
de chasse ou alors donc je dirais que
cette évolution est déjà été fait et que
les choses sont aujourd'hui presque
stabilisée qu'est ce que vous entendez
par méthodes de chasse c'est un peu
vague méthodes de chasse et puis même
dans l'organisation de la battue
la forme de labatut
sessad vraiment dans la pratique la rue
et dans la pratique la sueur j'écoutais
à part à part le côté sécurité à qui est
extrêmement cadré
après je vais vous dire il faut bien
imaginer que soyons présents si on les
grands lenoir effectivement général
n'est pas une question blanc c'est
vraiment j'y viens à l'appréciation que
je
on évoque que les accidents sont plutôt
dans les battues donc je verrai ce que
justement est ce que ces battues elles
se disent on dans les battues
naturellement parce que c'est là bas tu
qu'on est obligé de pratiquer le plus
pour prélever les grands animaux pour
tuer les grands animaux il n'y a pas
d'autre solution il ya un petit peu d'
approche qui d'ailleurs se vulgarise de
plus en plus c'est vrai mais entre
guillemets excusez moi dans la
rentabilité pas parce que nous demande
l'état le monde agricole les préfets
j'en passe et des meilleurs c'est
largement insuffisant
on peut pas faire quelques pas évoluer
le principe même de la battue labatut
permet effectivement de de chasser au
mieux les grands animaux même si
quelques prélèvements parallèles sont
toujours importants ce que nous faisons
dans beaucoup de départements
l'approchent l'affût voire même le tir
de nuit dans certains cas et dans
certains départements aujourd'hui qui
sont déjà mis en place bon qui le
montrent d'ailleurs quand même des
formations tout le monde peut pas faire
ce genre de choses donc moi je pense que
le système même de la battue c'est pas
pour autant que c'est c'est pas pour
rien que c'est le même système dans le
monde entier pour tirer des sangliers à
la chasse pour pour les trouver et des
chiens et pour enfermer un quart est
correctement et pour en tirer entre rim
et le plus possible quand on nous le
demande ben je vois pas comment faire
autrement qu utilisaient la battue même
si alors elle est ne nous trompons pas
non plus elle représente un nombre
d'accidents parce que c'est la pratique
de chasse la plus répandue et de façon
plus que majoritaire
je sais pas on a on n'a pas ce détail
d'ailleurs mais votre question me donne
une idée je regarderai quel est le
pourcentage animaux prélevés en dehors
de la battue il doit être extrêmement
faible c'est moins 5 % peut-être deux
peut-être un peut-être 3% c'est de cet
ordre là donc je le redis à part
utiliser le système de là battus grand
gibier je vois pas bien comment on va
faire autrement pour effectivement
équilibrer les populations de grands
animaux
même pour le petit gibier c'est pareil
d'ailleurs c'est ce que nous ont souvent
alors notre volet vous l'avez évoqué
sont les relations avec les non
chasseurs et avec les autres
utilisateurs de la nature vous avez cité
donc plusieurs
chartes signées par votre fédération
avec d'autres fédérations
quel bilan pouvez vous faire de ces deux
de ces
chartes ou de signatures
vous avez aussi en partie répondu mais
je me permet de reposer les questions
sur la généralisation des applications
signalement localisation des battus il
ya une question également je juge les
groupes parce qu'elles seront ressembler
ce sont soit même thème
donc à une question sur l'a10 les
distances de sécurité autour des
bâtiments qui est un sujet qui revient
souvent mais aussi haut sur les zones
touristiques qui sont fréquentes et où
la chasse pourrait être limitée ou
interdites et puis enfin
bon ce cette série de questions qui
regroupe
le thème de des relations avec avec les
non chasseurs c'est la question du jour
sans chasse uniforme ou pas sur le
territoire national quel est votre avis
même si je crois avoir perçu des ja oui
évidemment on va commencer par le jour
sans chasse elle monsieur rapporté savez
moi j'ai du mal à comprendre qu'on
puisse disposer du bien d'autrui pour
impôts pour pour expliquer un moment
qu'il y aura des journées l'interdiction
d'une pratique légale
sur son propre bien c'est leur propriété
alors vous savez le partage de la nature
comme comme certains le veulent et le
répète à cor et à cri d'ailleurs c'est
possible et c'est déjà le cas c'est le
domaine public dans une forêt domaniale
on chasse pas tous les jours ses jours
sont indiqué préalablement sont
consultables sur le site de lonay s'il
n'est pas toujours mis à jour cet
affreux mais normalement c'est le cas et
c'est même indiqué à chaque entrée de
2,2 de chemin en fin de route
carrossable dans la forêt ça veut dire
qu' il ne peut pas y avoir de problème
puisque tout le monde sait qu'en vont se
passer ses journées qui occupent
d'ailleurs un temps très faible par
rapport aux possibilités qui sont donnés
je rappelle quand même les as tu déjà la
chasse se passe en hiver ou en automne
donc à un moment où théoriquement le
temps est moins beau d'ailleurs ya pas
mal de journée on voit jamais grandmont
vu qu'on est sous la pluie ou dans le
froid mais néanmoins on croise quelqu'un
ici on croise quelqu'un même dans cette
semaine la lowé nef fait très attention
et la selle de mètres de l'état c'est
quelque part le vôtre mesdames et
messieurs les choses sont parfaitement
cadré c'est à dire il ya des jours de
données pour la chasse en fonction du
positionnement géographique de d'une
forêt il peut y avoir exclusion du
week-end est venue mercredi parce qu'on
est sur une forêt périurbaine ce que
tout le monde comprend parfaitement y
compris le monde de la chasse parce que
de toute façon on n'a aucun intérêt se
retrouve à chasser au milieu du monde ce
serait ridicule et puis personne serez à
l'aise nous les premiers donc il n'y a
pas d'intérêt à faire ça donc les choses
sont déjà bien établie après au vent
dans le domaine privé vous êtes chez
vous nous chasser chez vous c'est votre
propriété
comment on arrivait à dire qu'à un
moment pendant une journée vous n'allez
pas pouvoir
effectivement pratiqué votre chasse
parce que des gens seraient susceptibles
d'entrer chez vous dans votre domaine
privé
on a peut-être une partie des réponses à
l'engagement en france
malheureusement que je ne partage pas
mais que je comprends réflective mans
quand on parle de cette journée de non
chasse voilà par contre dans le début de
deux de vos questions
les chasseurs ne peuvent pas rester je
dirais à côté d'une réalité les gens
entrent dans la nature plus qu'il ya
deux ans plus qu'il ya cinq ans
puisqu'il ya dix ans les mille fois plus
qu'il ya 30 ans
donc qu'on soit dans le domaine privé je
l'entends que ce soit ou le droit de
propriété qui l'opprimé je l'entends
mais aujourd'hui il faut vivre avec son
temps donc moi je pense qu'il faut pas
partir du principe comme on le fait à
travers ses associations ses grandes
fédérations que le plus important c'est
d'abord un dialogue de terrain voilà on
n'a jamais interdit quelqu'un de
traverser un bon quand on chasse et on
ne se serait même pas posé la question
et 10 ans et quand on se croisait on
disait bonjour non des civils avaient
trouvé des champignons et de demander ce
qu'on avait tous les à la chasse et
c'était aussi simple que ça tout ça
beaucoup changé pour réseaux sociaux ont
fait un mal considérable dans ses
relations humaines qu'on peut avoir sur
sur les territoires ruraux moi je pense
qu'il faut qu'on accélère nous de notre
côté sur plus de communication
effectivement avec les usagers de la
nature qui sont des gens locaux donc
tout à fait conscient que le partage
s'opère dans le domaine public et c'est
déjà le cas et si est déjà le cas bien
que nous soyons les seuls à payer pour y
chasser je tiens aussi à le rappeler
c'est sûrement grâce à nous à notre
présence qui parfois est mal compris ce
qui a ou d aussi beaux chemins qui
traversent nos forêts domaniales parce
que vous savez que la chasse est quatre
à cinq fois plus rentable pour le nf que
le prix effectivement de bois ni
blessure la période de la vie la dame
qui représente plutôt une batte end
euros de l'hectare donc la chasse
représente beaucoup plus mais c'est pas
gênant ça ne pose pas de problème mais
par contre deux en venir effectivement
entrée sur la notion de propriété privée
remettre ça en cause
c'est très difficile à accepter en ce
qui me concerne je ne comprends pas la
démarche voilà la nature n'est pas à
tout le monde nous sommes prêts à
partager de la sphère imposer un journal
en chasse non moi je préfère qu'on
travaille la communication les changes
comme on le fait toujours et c'est vers
ça c'est pas sur un nouvel interdit
qu'on réglera les problèmes ça je suis
sûr que ça aura un effet dévastateur au
niveau des territoires et il ya des gens
qui finiront par tous fermés ou
barricadé ou je ne sais quoi ou mettre
des gens dehors ou voilà et ça c'est pas
une bonne chose ne mettons pas plus de
haine et de violence qui peut y en avoir
à travers les réseaux sociaux qui
rebondissent aujourd'hui sur les
territoires ruraux
pardon
oui
c'est vraiment le dialogue on discute
d'une déclinaison nationale on se
connaissait pas du tout quand même on
s'est retrouvés on s'est rassemblé
c'était pas facile il y avait des
tensions y avait beaucoup de tension les
vététistes et chasseurs tout ça ça se
regarde un petit peu en chien de fusil
aujourd'hui on a l'impression quand on
se croise
et que les uns ont valu aux autres enfin
voilà puisque parce qu'on vit tous dans
cette pression maintenant médiatique et
très forte contre la chasse et certains
politiques en sont largement
responsables encore pour cette
présidentielle d'ailleurs il faut savoir
le dire donc on a dit on va plutôt
discuter tout le monde est venu
puisqu'il est quand même extraordinaire
et tout le monde a eu la sagesse en
oubliant tous ces préjugés qu'on peut
avoir contre la chasse est pourtant que
je sais c'est facile d'en trouver dakar
la télévision à la radio ou les réseaux
sociaux et on s'est mis à discuter moi
je veux que l'achat soit m'expliquer si
on a fait une erreur monsieur le
rapporteur on l'a fait à des années
c'est qu'on s'est replié sur nous mêmes
et qu'on n'a pas expliqué ce qu'on
faisait parce qu'à un moment on s'est
dit on va arrêter de parler aux autres
ça c'était une erreur s'il ya une chose
qu'on doit réparer c'est dans la
communication parce que la chasse dans
le front c'est pas dangereux
oui à des accidents dramatiques des fois
et je le regretterai toujours mais au vu
de d'autres pratiques c'est beaucoup
moins dangereux que notre pratique voilà
il ya dans le fond peu de gens qui
perdent la vie à part nous même de temps
en temps je vous l'accordé aussi mais
moi je crois en la communication je
crois en ce dialogue national cette
alliance de la nature qui s'est créée
ces échanges ne serait-ce que créer un
premier panneau compris et partagé par
tout le monde qu'on a disputés ensemble
dans ses couleurs dans sa façon
effectivement de se présenter dans le qr
code qui a dessus et expliquer qu'à tout
randonneur
quand on a imaginé un je suis désolé
pour un peu de temps là-dessus mais
c'est important quand on a imaginé ce
panneau que voilà d'ailleurs mais quand
on a imaginé ce panneau on a posé un peu
de questions aux autres associations
pour ceux qui sont chasseurs dans la
salle vous allez comprendre quand
quelqu'un n'est pas chasseur et qu'il
arrive près d'un quart est chassé nous
on éventre au bois ce qu'on appelle
effectivement trop bas pour tirer
justement à l'extérieur de ce carré pour
quelqu'un qui ne connaît rien il pense
que quand on touche le bois d'à côté
c'est de ce côté-là continent premier
rang magistral celle inverse
c'est totalement la verte donc c'est
vraiment dans la communication de la
pratique et c'est pas parce qu'on est
sur un endroit on voit le panneau on
sait aussi qu'à ce moment là on a plein
d'autres endroits dans la forêt ou dans
les champs qui ne sont pas chassés là
aussi c'est de la discussion alors je le
disais dans mes propos liminaire on a
des gens aussi qui ne sont pas dans le
monde associatif et nous on prône
aujourd'hui une communication
directement au niveau communal c'est pas
un problème de signifier les jours on va
chasser à la société de chasse locale et
faire le tour des 80 dernières boîtes
aux lettres qui reste dans ce petit
village rural de france pour expliquer
quel jour était le jour et elles
joueront sera la chasse est pas un
problème et moi je vais prendre ça
aujourd'hui au niveau des fédérations on
doit mieux communiquer ensemble sur le
territoire c'est vers ça qu'on va
effectivement tendre avec les non
usagers avec les autres usagers de la
nature vers le zéro accident que voilà
et cette compréhension et surtout
enlever cette détestation qui se met en
place et qui est attisée par des gens
qui ont tout intérêt effectivement à
faire disparaître la chasse voilà donc
on sert effectivement d'un accident de
genre de choses pour avoir des grandes
idées lumineuses mais c'est parce c'est
pas avec ça qu'on réglera le problème de
communication de terrain c'est vraiment
la première chose qu'il faut mettre en
place échanger avec les gens des
communes échanger avec les gens qui
pratiquent sur un même territoire de
toute façon si la chasse devait un jour
être tirées de j'irai de de son activité
l'activité le week-end où les vacances
comme comme j'entends dans certains
programmes président présidentielle je
pense qu'après l'achat ce sera autre
chose la détestation du chasseur
s'arrêtera peut-être on prendra on aura
la détestation du vététiste on aura la
détestation du cavalier parce que ça
aussi
c'est quelque chose qui devient voilà je
pense que l'intolérance aujourd'hui est
tellement forte qu'on en oublie
l'essentiel est qu'on oublie de regarder
que simplement nous avons fait diminuer
les allées les accidents d'une façon
incroyable et qu'on va continuer à le
faire encore et on a tous les outils
pour le faire dans nos mains
merci juste avant de passer la parole à
mes collègues qui ont quelques questions
à vous poser sur les jours de chasse sur
les jours non chassés dans les
fédérations est ce que vous avez un état
des lieux par fédération parce que dans
toutes les fédérations il ya des jours
non chassés dans la semaine
c'est dedans lancé le lundi
on est allé le sait le mardi vendredi
dans les hautes pyrénées c'est notre
jour
dans les hautes pyrénées c'est notre jeu
ça peut être le lundi et le
je dis vrai est-ce que vous avez un état
des lieux parce que c'est vrai que dans
tout dans tous les départements il ya
des journaux chasser dans la semaine
mais c'est pas pareil dans département
un autre a lorsque n'a pas peut-être à
creuser l'idée d'une harmonisation d'un
jour de chasse voilà c'est une idée sans
que ce soit forcément le samedi ou le
dimanche voilà après c'est tout dépend
du gibier je pense aussi tout dépend
aussi des pratiques de chasse sur les
départements chaque départ département
est différent bon ça c'est une question
que je vous pose est-ce que vous avez
cet état des lieux sur un
parent fédération quel jour de chasse il
ya quinze jours il ne chasse pas
regarder allons pendant vingt ans il est
terminé il ya moins de dix fédérations
qui ont un jour de non chasse en france
qui est plutôt historique d'ailleurs
souvent qu'ils correspondent quelque
chose bon je dirais de façon officielle
officieusement il ya le nombre de jours
de chasse est extrêmement faible tous
nous ont bien joué les chasseurs
pratiquent en moyenne 20 francs par an
il ya 365 jours dans une année je prends
l'exemple d'ailleurs parce qu'on ramène
les problèmes à déterrer part dans le
fonds qui sont très minoritaires ou
chasse les gens où il est en de façon le
général dans les villages sont jamais
perdre l'église de vue c'est souvent
comme ça qu'on définit les choses dans
le village les gens ils savent que c'est
la chasse le dimanche et que les
premiers dimanches jusqu'à ce que en
approche de noël souvent vers le 15
décembre et puis a pris appui chasse et
saleuses et les chasse des villages et
c'est quand même entre nous quatre un
bond de 80% des territoires chasser
c'est quand même comme ça que ça se
passe donc naturellement il ya déjà six
jours où c'est pas chasser naturellement
après on rentre sur la propriété privée
on l'a déjà évoqué en domaniale ses
cadres et vous le savez après
effectivement il reste si on rentre sur
la propriété privée ou là c'est vrai il
peut y avoir des gens qui cherchent chez
eux un autre jour que le dimanche alors
c'est compliqué d'entrer sur un jour de
non chasse d'abord parce que tout le
monde va vouloir le même ceux qui
chassent et ceux qui chassent pas parce
que quand vous êtes occupés toutefois
que celle semaine dans le travail bon
évidemment c'est le week-end que vous
voulez conserver pour aller à la chasse
le dimanche aux priorités et sur mon
épaule samedi mais les autres vont dire
à quoi ça sert être le mardi de toute
façon ce jour ne peut pas y aller parce
que nous aussi on travaille donc je
pense je reviens ce que je disais avant
le jour de mon chasse ne réglera pas
hormis à attiser probablement beaucoup
durant centre les gens au niveau local
mais par contre mieux informés quand la
chasse se pratique sur le territoire
communal dans le cas où il ya des gens
qui ne le sauraient pas rassurez vous
dans 90 % 95 % des communes de france
tout le monde c'est le jour où la chasse
a lieu c'est à la casse et à la société
de chasse du village
après reste la problématique des
territoires privés nous avons justement
travailler tout de suite ces panneaux
avec les autres usagers de la nature
pour justement pallier cette partie là
domaniale ses cadres et on le sait si on
veut le savoir on sait tout de suite en
domaniale le village si on y habite on
sait très bien quand est-ce que ça
chasser ou sa chasse il reste ensuite
les territoires privés on a fait un
panneau avec les autres usagers de la
nature voilà là aussi même si on n'a pas
regardé avant même si on connaît pas
tout quand on arrivait qu'on voit chasse
en cours écoutez la commune elle est
grande on peut aller faire un petit tour
à tout petit peu plus loin c'est pas
dramatique les armes seront aussi vert
et il ya aussi des petits ruisseaux et
c'est aussi jolie à des oiseaux voilà je
pense qu'avec ces outils là avec une
communication forte au niveau local on
doit pouvoir aujourd'hui continuer à
vivre sans prendre une interdiction qui
serait quand même très difficilement
acceptable et est particulièrement
choquante surtout qu'on reparle quand
même de la propriété privée
merci avait demandé la parole
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur merci monsieur le président
de de vos propos très éclairé on sent
que vous avez effectivement envie de
sécuriser la chasse tout comme tout
alors je voudrais juste vous demander un
conseil je suis sénateur de saône et
loire un endroit où il ya beaucoup de
vignes beaucoup de champ le dimanche
matin comme tous mes collègues élus je
prends ma petite auto pour aller à
différentes manifestations et sur une
départementale très très passante de
chaque côté il ya ces magnifiques
panneaux que vous m'avez que vous allez
montrer à tout le monde attention chasse
en cours donc moi je suis dans ma petite
auto je fais quoi
j'accélère pour m'en aller vite de cet
endroit je vais tout doucement parce que
peut-être à chasseur va traverser ou un
gros animal ou alors est-ce qu'un
chasseur va me prendre pour cible ont
fait de si je comprends l'intérêt de ces
panneaux dans les champs dans les bois
dans les forêts je comprends pas bien le
long d'une départementale
alors même la sénatrice la prochaine
fois je vous propose de vous arrêter et
de flasher depuis apple vous aurez tous
les renseignements évidemment on va pas
faire comme ça j'ai compris vous étiez
en voiture
on met ça parce qu'on est dans une zone
ou à proximité d'une zone de chasse
alors dans le cas d'une dune d'une route
c'est surtout pour faire ralentir les
gens pas pour nous qui sont de tir de
carabine parce qu'on déplace désormais
des grands animaux as envie une
compagnie sans lier qui levait peut
faire plusieurs kilomètres effectivement
après avoir été tiré et souvent il
convient convient de les chasser donc
c'est surtout pour dire aux
automobilistes ralentissent et dans
cette zone vous pouvez avoir des animaux
qui fuit et et qui traverse brutalement
la route voilà ça fait aussi partie des
communications qu'on a autour de ce
panneau rassurez vous c'est en aucun cas
pour peut-être accéléré parce qu'on va
bientôt tirer heureusement d'ailleurs
non non c'est pas ça du tout mais c'est
la crise mais on rend dans une zone au
ralenti et aussi pour une autre chose
souvent si pour le chien parce que si
les animaux fui les chiens les suivent
aussi des fois et on a des chiens qui
peuvent se déplacer sur plusieurs
centaines de mètres voire 1 km2
l'impossible d'animaux et le temps qu'on
les récupère ton coran dans une zone
sensible où on doit plutôt décélérer
voilà il faire attention de ne pas voir
arriver un sanglier ou coup quelques
chemins qui traversent la route
la sénatrice je crois qu'il ya peut-être
un élément
qui est révélateur dans votre propos
c'est quand même on a un vrai déficit de
communication à l'égard de gens qui
n'ont plus de culture rurale qui n'ont
plus ni deux frères ni deux soeurs ni de
parents à la culture et là je pense
qu'on a commis une erreur pendant trop
longtemps on a pensé qu'on parlait entre
nous parce qu'on a les enjeux de
sécurité qu'il faut qu'on se font ce
cadre mais on n'a pas parlé aux autres
on n'a pas assez parlé aux autres et la
preuve c'est que le panneau c'est une
bonne chose mais vous dites ça veut dire
quoi c'est comme lorsque vous trouviez
un panneau danger tirs à balle qui était
plantée sur à nabeul qui restait du 1er
février au 31 décembre alors qu'on
chasse est quatre mois par an tout d'un
coup vous dites mais moi je me croyais
au mois de juillet mais mais c'est
dangereux mais en plus ce danger tirs à
balle vous pouvez imaginer que c'est pas
drôle donc je crois qu'on a un vrai
sujet c'est ce que disait willis ran
hong un vrai sujet d'informations avec
l'ensemble des habitants faut être
honnête il y à une psychose d'un certain
nombre de gens qui ne connaissent pas la
chasse et qui vivent à la campagne
opéré aux mains ou qui vont de la ville
à la campagne pour consommer la nature
et s'ils voient des panneaux qui leur
paraissent étranges ils vont avoir la
limite ça va plus c'est inquiété que les
rassurer donc je crois qu'on a un vrai
travail à faire parce que autant sur les
accidents on est il ya plutôt une très
bonne maîtrise autant sur la peur
d'aller se promener dans la nature on
est encore sur un vrai sujet et comme le
coville a démontré qu'on avait beaucoup
plus de gens qui voulaient aller dans la
nature mais qui n'ont pas de culture
alors comme on l'a dit les fédérations
elles forment leurs licenciés elle leur
donne des consignes ils reçoivent un
bulletin mais le quidam et qui est
totalement légitime autant légitime
qu'un autre n'a pas d'informations on
doit avoir une communication dans les
communes dans toutes les maisons de
france qui paraît indispensable pour
expliquer la chasse est ce que dit
souvent qu israël sait que la chasse
elle elle a un déficit d'explication
parce qu'on ne chasse pas beaucoup on ne
chasse pas tous les jours c'est pas vrai
c'est il ya énormément de choses qu'on
ne fait pas alors qu'on nous le raconte
partout sur les réseaux sociaux mais
beaucoup de gens on le voit bien quand
on fait les enquêtes 50% des gens disent
j'aime pas la chasse parce que je la
connais pas sitôt japonais jeu bien même
s'il ne la pratiqueront pas et qui ne
comprennent rien des règles qu'on se
fixe donc on a un énorme travail
d'information du grand public
mais à une information de proximité
parce que comme vous l'avez souligné
tout à l'heure d'un département à
l'autre le monde change les pratiques
changent à la montagne ont fait on fait
des battues mais c'est dans des très
grandes surfaces alors que dans des
zones plutôt de plaine au fait des
battues dans les toutes petites surfaces
ou les choses sont différentes et on n'a
pas les mêmes chemins communaux ou les
chemins de randonnée donc il faut
expliquer les choses et là c'est le
travail je suis secrétaire général de
l'alliance d'espoir une mesure de la
nature on a réuni tous les utilisateurs
de la nature parce qu'ils considèrent
eux aussi qu'une vraie information y
compris dans tous les centres équestres
quand on va aller se balader il faut
qu'on fasse nous un effort énorme
d'informations qui n'est pas de la
propagande qui est juste de
l'explication de texte comment on
partage comment on utilise la nature
dans quelles conditions mais hélas c'est
à l'échelle proche puisque vous avez
fait leur à leurs marques sur les
schémas il faut se ramener à la réalité
du quotidien et ça on peut la fédération
nationale peu donné consigne mais il
faut une réalité du quotidien et on a un
gros travail sur ce sujet parce que on
aura gagné la vraie bataille sur la
sécurité je crois qu'on est en train de
gagner mais sur la crainte d'aller se
promener dans la nature c'est là où on
n'a pas gagné et c'est là on doit
travailler par contre effectivement
le tir non fichant c'est ce qui menace
directement on va dire les non chasseurs
on a en a ce cas de de ce décès de
l'automobiliste
là en automne 2021 qui est vraiment créa
flagrant d'une mauvaise utilisation
alors pour revenir à cette affaire
n'oublions pas que la personne avait un
poste attribué qui s'en est déplacé de
200 m s'il était resté à ce poste et
fichiers ses balles donc là on a
quelqu'un qui effectivement commet une
erreur majeure mais il n'y a rien à
rattraper la thur d'ailleurs peut-être
ce que je reviens quand même sur la peur
du gendarme et peut-être aussi sur un
durcissement peut-être de la justice
quand on se rend responsable de tendre
autant d'erreurs qui se suivent et qui
amène à la mort d'une personne qui
conduit une voiture c'est pas la chasse
le problème dans ces cas là c'est la
personne qui fait ces erreurs là et là
peut-être qu'il faut qu'on graduent
beaucoup plus effectivement les choses
parce que là je veux dire vous pouvez
être chef de battue vous pouvez mettre
quelqu'un à ce poste il ay là il à cet
enseignement ici et ce qu'ils doivent
faire y connaissez en lycée ou faut
tirer pas tirer quand tu irais pas tiré
et il brave tout ça parce qu'à un moment
peut-être qu'il a senti que rien ne
pouvait lui arriver ou qui pouvaient se
permettre de se déplacer voilà par
contre si les règles sont bien appliqués
sur les moines police suffisante ben
voilà on sait toute personne qui va
tirer une balle sur une plaine à 250
mètres après un chevreuil et vous avez
quand même notre chance sur dix de voir
cette balle continuer 103 km c'est ça le
problème donc là il va falloir là je
leur dis pas ce que je pense vraiment
gg je sais les efforts qu'on fait je
sais comment ils ressentent aujourd'hui
le manque de police ça c'est dramatique
c'est dramatique parce que je crains
qu'à un moment il ya une forme de
laxisme avec ça qu'ils se développent
voilà même si on a conscience du danger
voilà même si on sait que rouler très
vite avec un véhicule c'est beaucoup
plus dangereux si on a un accident ben
là c'est pareil tu vois de ne pas
respecter les règles de sécurité
basiques donc l'enjeu financier est
colossal colossal colossal par contre
effectivement nous on prend le tir
fichant et quand une balle n'est pas
fille chante on doit avoir des moyens
d'ailleurs ce qu'on n'avait pas tout à
fait jusque là mais qu'on développe à
travers maintenant cette commission
sécurité qui périssent dans les
fédérations
vous avez des gens qui sont coutumiers
d'un tir lointain ou qui ont mis
peut-être la dent en danger la vie
d'autrui à travers un tir moi j'invite
effectivement à tous ceux qui organisent
les battues a dénoncé genre de pratiques
on saura faire on saura faire quelqu'un
qui tient sur un animal en crète à 300 m
pour moi c'est quelqu'un qui mérite pas
de tenir une arme dans ses mains donc
donnons nous donnons nous donner nous
peut être aussi quelques moyens
supplémentaires pour être plus punitif
en interne de nos pratiques c'est
quelque chose de très très important
aussi pour le jeu le président parle je
leur apporte donc joui de deux questions
complémentaires vous vous évoquez
effectivement l'erreur
par rapport à un déplacement donc oui de
son poste l'erreur par rapport aux 30
degrés est mais et vous phase i cette
comparaison avec
quelqu'un qui roule à 150 km heure celui
qui roule à 50 km heure il a en face de
lui le code de la route
est ce que aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui se
déplacent de son poste on peut lui
imposer le code de la chasse donc ça
c'est vraiment une question fondamentale
vous voulez compléter et et je me
permets pas ce que je vais devoir moi
vous vous dites est absolument à 10h30
précises chez une autre un autre
engagement j'en suis vraiment désolé je
m'en excuse par avance si jamais on n'a
pas fini
vous parliez des moyens de police et
c'est une question vous avez donc évoqué
à plusieurs reprises selon vous faut-il
justement de renforcer les pneus mais je
crois savoir quand réponse mais aussi
renforcer les pouvoirs des agents
assermentés des fédérations pour
justement pouvoir jouer un rôle
supplémentaire en matière de police ce
matin parce que tout repose là-dessus on
reprend dans cet exemple dramatique
qui vraiment est très récent puisqu'il
date de l'automne
même même le président la chasse qu'est
ce qui peut faire contre quelqu'un qui
n'a pas respecté peut l'exclure je te
graver que vous ça c'est facile il peut
l'exclure du coup tu rentres chez toi je
veux plus de voix bon c'est pas toujours
facile non plus aidé bien servi aux
copains et peut-être que c'est la
première fois qu'il fait une bêtise bon
néanmoins si on avait une police à la
hauteur de l'enjeu et quand puisse
contrôler genre de choses parce que là
c'est pas qu'on puisse pas mettre de pvc
faut-il encore avoir les gens pour le
faire c'est ça le problème l'om et nam
que je respecte beaucoup
et tout le monde connaît le travail de
pierre dubreuil à la tête de cet office
bon a tellement d'autres choses à faire
que sept petites mains de la police de
la police de proximité
les gens lui n'est plus assurée alors
nous sommes quelques fédérations à le
faire c'est vrai
j'en fait partie d'ailleurs moi dans mon
pas de calais j'ai quand même plus d'une
quinzaine de personnes qui font de la
prise de la chasse en permanence bon
j'ai pas trop d'accidents peut-être ça
vient de là j'en sais rien je suis moi
de ne pas en avoir à demain on à l'abri
de rien mais par contre il ya aussi
beaucoup de présidents de fédérations
qui me disent moi j'ai pas de police
parce que je suis pris dans des dégâts
ce que moi je n'ai pas effectivement ou
très peu au nord pas de calais où mon
budget passe à payer des dégâts de
sangliers à longueur d'année j'ai plus
de moyens de faire autre chose que payer
des dégâts longueur d'année de sangliers
donc s'il y avait quelques agents de
développement moment et ben j'ai dû
effectivement me résoudre à autre chose
parce que j'ai plus de moyens financiers
donc je pense vraiment que là ce côté
police alors je t'avais dit dans les
propos liminaire que vous avez
partiellement lieu au sénat mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs bon peut-être d
or je pense en imaginant pas qu'on
aurait une portée
aussi horrible j'ai pas vu que c'était
humanité ou non plus faire seulement
mais mais voilà ça a été enlevé au sinaï
c'est dommage parce qu'on a d'ailleurs
beaucoup moins de police de possibilités
de police qu'avant puisque c'est même
pire que ça pour nos agents aujourd'hui
il faut quand même le savoir pour ceux
qui ne le savent pas pour qu'on puisse
aller verbaliser quelqu'un au sur un
territoire il faut avoir l'autorisation
de cette personne sur son propre
territoire vous imaginez que ça devient
quand même compliqué est-ce que je peux
venir vugar balisés si c'est non c'est
non vous n'y allez pas donc un vrai un
vrai problème de police
par rapport aux codes on peut
effectivement verbaliser sauf qu'on a
pas les qu'on n'a pas les personnes pour
le faire aujourd'hui
on peut considérer qu'on peut qu'on voit
là on peut considérer à l'ong le tir
dans l'angle de 30 en dehors de l'ordre
de 30 degrés
quelqu'un qui tira sans vie à 15 degrés
comme ça et d'ailleurs il ya un pv qui a
été bien quelques jours dans le nord des
choix sur simplement un constat visuel
parce qu'ils ont des agents de
fédération qui peuvent être en
permanence sur le terrain un pv a été
mis parce que la personne à turin sont
liés et que les agents le voit faire il
arrive qu'entre les l'a battu dans un
angle de moins de 30 degrés eh bien ils
ont dressé procès-verbal cette personne
n'ira probablement la commission de
sécurité
moi je le demanderai et que cette
personne ait une suspension de permis
suffisamment significative pour qu'ils
prennent conscience de son acte c'est
toujours pareil une fois qu'on a plus
personne sur les territoires pour le
pont pour le contrôle comment voulez
vous comment voulez-vous d'abord que les
gens aient peur et en plus comment
voulez vous qu'on verbalise puisqu'il ya
personne on a tellement peu le genre
dispositions là dedans et on nous a
enlevé toute une partie de la police
pour ce que pour aller sur ce territoire
faut avoir l'autorisation en plus
maintenant on peut même pas piquer le
schéma de gestion départemental sis
getti qu'on peut même pu le faire avec
nos fédérations c'est dramatique 1 de
cette situation
daniel salmon
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
président dans votre propos introductif
vous avez employé beaucoup le mot
ennemis sachent est ici dans cette
mission d'information on n'a pas
d'ennemi en face de nous on n'a que des
citoyens on les écoute on les écoute
tous dans leur diversité parce qu'on a
on recherche un peu la même chose que
vous ce que vous disiez plutôt vers la
fin de votre propos c'est qu'on cherche
à avoir une société plus apaisé une
société qui se comprennent et avec des
chants qui qui se respecte donc il n'ya
pas de dogmatisme ni quoi que ce soit
donc notre mission c'est de chercher
davantage de sûreté alors effectivement
on peut ce
qu'on peut se satisfaire que les
chiffres montrent qu'il y à une
amélioration qui est nette depuis
quelques dizaines d'années mais il nous
semble légitime
nous en tant que parlementaire de nous
poser la question également comment
faire pour aller encore un peu plus loin
donc on n'est pas du tout nous
semble-t-il illégitime pour faire pour
faire ce travail à
je voudrais simplement venir sur sur un
fake puisque je suis d'ille-et-vilaine
sénateur d'ille-et-vilaine et donc à
l'endroit où il ya eu 7 ce décès sur la
quatre voies mais je sais pas ce sur
celui-là de celui là que je vous parlais
je vous parlais d'un autre fait qui
s'est passé à quelques quelques
kilomètres de la chanteuse où j'ai
rencontré un chasseur
un chasseur qui a une pratique de chasse
depuis une trentaine d'années et qui a
eu une valve qui a atterri dans la
chambre de sa fille
et ce chasseur je les trouvais très amer
quelque part ce le mot qui lui revenait
souvent c'était dégoûté un chasseur
blessé mais blessé pas physiquement mais
dense et dans son âme de chasseurs parce
qu'il n'a pas été du tout considérés par
la fédération de chasse je pense que on
parlait de diallo octobre je pense qu'il
doit y avoir aussi du dialogue entre les
chasseurs parce que
je vais vous dire ce qui lui a été le
courrier qu'il a reçu je vous lis juste
un morceau
il ya quand même une balle qui
traversent
le toit qui éclate la charpente et qui
atterrit près du lit de sa fille
heureusement elle était banal en cas de
faute aux règles élémentaires de
sécurité nous nous réservons la
possibilité de prendre des mesures à
l'égard de ces chasses au vu de vos
déclarations restant à votre disposition
ça fait plusieurs mois mais personne
n'est venu le voir
rien et de victimes il est passé presque
en accusation parce que la fédération de
chasse à communiquer son nom est donc la
personne d'où venait où est allé là bas
tu
le propriétaire lui a envoyé une lettre
à ses je vais pas dire menaçante mais il
le menace de porter plainte contre lui
donc lui purement victime se retrouve
menacée donc je pense que à ce niveau là
je ne sais pas ce que vous pouvez faire
mais il y a aussi du dialogue à avoir
parce que il ya un sentiment de trahison
et je pense que j'en viens à notre parti
de mon propos je pense que la famille
les chasseurs c'est un peu une famille
et qu'il ya certainement des choses qui
ne sort pas non plus de cette famille et
il faut que et bien les différents fai
puissent s'exprimer et je pense que
également vallier de pouvoir faire un
contrôle par vos propres par des agents
assermentés
je pense qu'il faut vraiment avoir des
gens qui viennent de l'extérieur aussi à
peut-être qu'ils viendraient du monde de
la chasse mais pas des proches parce que
vous l'avez dit vous-même si vous faites
si vous chassiez avec votre copain
depuis 30 ans ça va pas être facile pour
vous de porter un acte de retraite donc
une sanction donc je pense que vraiment
là il faut avoir cette vision là pour
avoir la distance la distance nécessaire
pour pouvoir sanctionner dernière chose
je reviens à ces deux ces deux accidents
qui sont posées qui sont passés presque
au même endroit à chaque fois le tireur
était sur un point haut
et avec une carabine chaque fois des
balles qui ont fait
800 900 mille mètres qui ont traversé
d'ailleurs plusieurs est
effectivement pas de chance ils n'ont
pas pris de branche
voilà alors je m'interroge sur ce
positionnement
on parle de tir fichant quand on est sur
un point haut à voir un tir fichant
c'est pas facile c'est très compliqué à
moins d'avoir un super mirador donc
voilà je pense qu'il ya des règles
effectivement mais il faut faire en
sorte qu'il soit le mieux respecté
possible même si on le sait la
perfection n'est pas humaine merci merci
monsieur le sénateur
vous parle effectivement de ce qu'a dit
des vilaines donc j'ai pas entendu
parler d'ailleurs personnellement donc
voilà mais comme vous me l'avez expliqué
très très très clairement dans vos
propos liminaire si vous me demandez de
ne pas tenir compte effectivement da
présente certaines associations
effectivement et que vous êtes en droit
de recevoir qui vous voulez même ceux
qui ont plutôt tendance à se promener
des cribles et des battes de baseball au
jour des jeux le journée des chats sont
en périphérie de la grande couronne
parisienne
je vous demanderais de faire pareil pour
le cadet libyenne qui est sûrement un
cas unique ne voyons pas non plus
toujours là où les choses ne sont pas
bien passées et peut-être dans plein
d'autres cas où les fédérations ont fait
ce qu'elle devait faire et j'espère que
c'est comme ça mais j'entends et je
vérifierai ce cas monsieur le sénateur
vous parlez de police de la chasse
j'entends jean temps j'entends ce que
vous me dites un peu sourire mais vous
oubliez juste quand même que la police
de la chasse sont des gens qui ont créé
un magret mans de police ont fait pas
d'eux on fait on fait pas de favoritisme
contre un policier ce sont des vrais
policiers de la nature que nous avons
c'est pas des copains qui revoit des
copains la chasse le dimanche ce sont
des vrais policiers d'ailleurs pouvez
vérifier dans les fédérations nous avons
un corps de police comme la mienne je
peux vous dire qu'il ya une règle qui
est qui et qui est mise en place dès le
début que ce soit avec ma police
fédérale et chloé avait d'ailleurs c'est
que le président c'est interdit comme
tout administrateur et nous s'ils n'ont
pas bien ce sens a demandé la moindre
clémence en cas de pv qui est instaurée
c'est la moindre des choses et je peux
vous dire que la police fédérale ne fait
pas de cadeau à personne et c'est très
bien comme ça et c'est normal et ils ont
un agrément qui est renouvelé par le
préfet je peux vous dire que c'est
surveillé donc par contre ils ont cette
compétence naturel de pouvoir oeuvrer
mieux que personne pour reconnaître
effectivement la problématique c'est pas
si facile que ça quand on n'est pas
chasseur et combien de l'extérieur pour
bien comprendre à quel moment il ya une
faute dans quelque chose donc je pense
qu'au contraire il faut faire confiance
à ces gens d'ailleurs qui aujourd'hui
sont sont pour la plupart n'oublions pas
que c'est bien les agents de fédérations
qui sont rentrés l oncfs avec la police
donc ils viennent tous de formation
fédérales dont quand même pas dire
qu'aujourd'hui les gens du web et qui
feront la police sont des gens qui sont
qui reconnaissent des ennemis à la
chasse et qui ne font pas leur travail
et pourtant ils viennent naturellement
des fédérations de chasseurs
avant effectivement la loi qui a modifié
sa il ya une bonne vingtaine d'années
pour terminer j'entends ce que vous
dites qu'il faut regarder le poids au le
point bas normalement contenu sur une
route sur une hauteur et contient dans
un bas-fond principe aux fiches chabal
bon par contre si vous êtes sur une
hauteur et vous tirez sur la hauteur
d'en face alors évidemment alors là et
on revient toujours à ce tout ce qu'on a
dit dans ce cas là qu'on est un peu de
moyens qu'on puisse effectivement donné
par un peu plus aux chasseurs qui ont
l'habitude de gens de bêtises les
sanctionner plus facilement par contre
une chose qui est important dans ce que
vous avez dans vos propos juste avant
c'est que moi je parle aux chasseurs et
et madame la présidente a bien fait de
lire ce que j'avais fait en 2019
j'incite les gens à dénoncer
systématiquement et je les ai écrits
noir sur blanc les comportements
dangereux ça rentre dans les moeurs je
dis pas qu'il ya 20 ans c'était
impossible à force de le répéter et
quand c'est le président national qui le
dit
même si c'est ton copain d'aidé et que
tes copains avec depuis 30 ans pitt a
été à l'école avec ses biens pour le
bien d'aider et tous les autres qui
chasse avec lui il faut savoir un moment
d'énoncer effectivement que le cochon et
sa j'insiste et je rappelle sans cesse
publiquement partout où je passe que
c'est parce que c'est un ami justement
qu'il faut lui dire et savoir le dire à
un moment si ça ne veut pas donc au
contraire je ne veux pas qu'on cache des
choses et je veux pas et je ne veux pas
qu'on tombe effectivement dans une une
sorte je dirais de deux mauvaises amici
à travers des exactions qui pourrait
être fait ou d invisibilité au niveau de
la chasse voilà pour le bien de tous il
faut passer au-dessus de ça et croyez
bien que la police fédérale le fait très
très bien je vous assure
on est oubliés une petite parce que je
voulais vous pousser un petit peu d'or
mais
on a parlé de journées sans chasse je
vois bien que ça ne recueille pas votre
assentiment
alors alors un petit peu plus loin
parlons de deux mi journée sans chasse
jeudi au hasard le dimanche après midi
est ce que parce que nous sommes dans
une société vous le dites vous même côté
sociétés qui est assez bloquer une
société où il ya de la défiance de tout
le monde les uns envers les autres il ya
un moment faut savoir faire aussi pour
être compris il faut savoir faire un un
petit pas ou un grand pas donc voila
j'aimerais vous entendre là dessus est
ce que c'est pour vous c'est niet le 10
victoires on n'en veut pas ou est ce que
et bien il ya des années et toujours des
négociations regroupent là donc je sais
pas alors on va quand même pas rentrer
dans le marchandage de tapis tous les
deux ce sénateur disons une heure et
demie on tranche non non non non non non
mais là encore les temps changent
mais les temps changent dans la pratique
de la chasse aussi il ya beaucoup de
sociétés de chasse communale aujourd'hui
et vous pourrez le vérifier j'en parle
en connaissance de cause c'est le cas
pour mon village où nous fermons
maintenant la chasse à 14 heures et à 14
heures on chasse plus voilà et ça se
passe très bien bon nous c'est une
chasse de petits gibiers donc voilà ça
pose pas de problème
là encore les gens du village le savent
parce qu'on a communiqué parce qu'on
discute avec eux et qu'ils savent qu'à
14 ans choses plus ça pose pas de
problème mais on est sur quelque part
les voies publiques de la commune
puisqu'on est dans les champs agricoles
bon je rassure sur la notion de
propriété privée et qui à mes yeux vous
l'avez compris cette notion de propriété
privée je ne peux pas je ne peux pas la
remettre en cause parce qu'elle me et je
trouve choquant de le faire à titre
personnel par contre effectivement tout
peut décoder discuter mais dans ce cas
là laissons les gens localement rivet ce
problème et je pense que c'est la bonne
chose il ya des mères quand même et au
sénat on sait ce que ça veut dire une
mairesse ou un maire et voilà et s'il ya
effectivement un partage à faire au
niveau local les sont effectivement les
maires en discuter avec les usagers de
la nature et trouve c'est d'ailleurs
souvent ce qui se passe parce qu'il ya
des biens communaux qui sont chassés
maintenant dans plein d'endroits et ça
se fait toujours déjà par une discussion
entre les différents usagers de la
nature et bien sûr les chasseurs qui
vont chasser
je pense pas en protéines moi je suis
d'une région minière le pas de calais
qui doivent être chassés régulièrement
parce qu'il pose des problèmes il ya
beaucoup de lapins des compromis sont
trouvés un week-end sur trois des fois
un samedi matin des fois c'est la
commande de semaine c'est la semaine et
c'est pas le week-end tout le monde est
au courant et le maire a fait distribuer
le papier et ça se passe très bien sans
pour autant prendre de grandes décisions
au niveau d'une loi nationale où on va
je pense mal répondre à une situation
sur laquelle je reviens j'ai pas dit au
revoir monsieur le rapporteur j'avais le
site et pardon je saluerai de ma part ou
je crois que le fondamental ce sénateur
c'est ce qu'on n'arrête pas de répéter
tout à l'heure la communication au
niveau local c'est là où on va trouver
effectivement la possibilité entre
chasseurs non chasseurs même les gens
qui n'aiment pas la chasse si on arrive
au niveau des communes à mieux discuter
de cette pratique de chasse voilà on va
de toute façon diminué pour beaucoup
j'irai cette 7è nous cette violence
montante qu'on a aujourd'hui entre
chasseurs et non chasseurs il n'empêche
que la sécurité doit être poussé à son
maximum comme nous le faisons tous les
jours et ça c'est autre chose on est
bien à col en parle du partage de la
nature
il ya une petite dernière question que
j'aurais à vous poser si mes collègues
en terminer sur les accidents et les
incidents répertoriés dont vous avez
connaissance avez vous une idée
des causes principales quel type de
manquement reviennent le plus souvent en
termes de mode avait dit en termes de
sécurité souvent sceller les l'angle des
30 degrés est ce que vous avez une idée
de
majoritairement quel type de manquement
reviennent plus souvent ces langues les
30 degrés après j'insiste sur le fait de
karim aussi entre guillemets la faute à
pas de chance on a vu des gens mourir
d'une balle qui ricochent alors que la
balle ait tiré à 45 degrés hélas écrit
ce que vous voulez il ya une chance sur
un million que ça se passe comme ça mais
temps en temps ça arrive serra il ya une
chose qui me choque profondément
c
c'est des gens qui tirent sans avoir
identifié quelque chose et ça je peux
pas comprendre je ne peux pas comprendre
et pour ce genre de tir
pour comme blancs d'autres randonnées
d'ailleurs un voilà je le dis souvent
c'est traité comme un accident
quand on accumule les fautes comme temps
certains accidents et particulièrement
pour le la mort de monsieur qui fait
qu'on se retrouve aujourd'hui c'est plus
un accident quand il ya autant de
bêtises accumulé c'est un meurtre à un
moment il faut voilà donc s'il ya un
moyen quelque chose à faire là dedans il
faudra le faire et ça servira la chasse
d'ailleurs quoi qu'on en dise et ça
servira la sécurité
bien des côtés merci beaucoup je suis
vous avez une conclusion si je vous
laisse conclure et puis je vais si bien
commencée c'est gentil à vous merci dont
je voulais vous remercie bien sûr l'âme
la présente mesure à porter vous lui
direz et mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je voulais profiter effectivement de de
cette fin d'entretien pour parler de
certains faits qui vont retouché
d'ailleurs le problème sécuritaire ou
tout au moins le problème de la haine la
violence et de l'incompréhension qui qui
tourne autour de cette chasse
aujourd'hui
alors je sais effectivement que ces
propos pour encore m'amener plein de
plein de problèmes mais on y est
habitués et surtout beaucoup de menaces
de mort mais
je reviens à ces menaces effectivement
qui sont proférées sur les réseaux
sociaux malheureusement souvent en toute
impunité
à quand une véritable loi pour endiguer
ce mât de notre société qui touche
malheureusement perpétuellement ces deux
mondes de nombreux chasseurs à la
famille subissent comme moi aujourd'hui
des harcèlements d'une rare violence à
partir des réseaux sociaux et dans les
sanctions pénales se résume trop souvent
à de simples stage de citoyenneté
depuis quelques années plusieurs jeunes
se sont suicidés en lien directe à leur
appartenance avec le monde cynégétique
suit effectivement ces harcèlements les
réponses des tribunaux sont
malheureusement pas toujours à la
hauteur du calvaire que vit ces
personnes et leurs familles et qui n'ont
malheureusement ni ma facilité ni mes
moyens de président de fmc a eu en
justice pour obtenir réparation
même si celle-ci quelque part est
dérisoire que dire aussi j'ai trois
points la présidente que lire aussi
cette propagande anti chasse qui se
développe dorénavant sein même de nos
écoles là où l'on voit une certaine
bienveillance de certains rectorats
laisser passer d ouvrage de propagande
au programme scolaire ou en périphérie
de celui-ci traitant de la méchanceté
des chasseurs a tué bambi ses amis de la
forêt les champs je voulais revenir là
dessus parce que pas plus tard que la
semaine dernière dans l'école de dan un
petit village du pas de calais un livre
sans équivoque a été distribué aux
enfants présentant les chasseurs comme
des êtres sans empathie menaçant les
manier les animaux et bien plus bien sûr
et comment se fait-il que certaines
associations anti tous ont le droit de
faire du militantisme auprès nos enfants
contre la chasse la pêche l'élevage ou
l'alimentation carnée pendant les heures
de l'école républicaine
et tout cela sans contrôle ni
contradictoires alors que nos structures
fédérales sont pourtant toutes agréées
et en matière de protection de la nature
et ne peuvent toujours pas
officiellement intervenir pour parler de
biodiversité ordinaire dans les classes
en raison du dogmatisme de certaines
académies j'en viens au troisième et
dernier point qui devrait d'ailleurs
faire couler un peu d'encre et de salive
dans les jours qui viennent et je vais
vous remettre la une du magazine
cynégétique nos chasses que je vous fait
voir de loin madame la présidente mais
je voulais né qui relève dans les
moindres détails le fonctionnement et
les agissements de certains groupuscules
anti chasse soit antispécistes peut-être
qu'ils passeront devant vous
le repenti de nommer alexis parmi nous
raconte une histoire un peu folle sur
l'organisation structurelle de ces
groupes d'action leurs financements
occultes par de grandes associations
animalistes à coude enveloppes d'argent
liquide dont on ignore d'ailleurs
l'origine et comment ces associations
sont aussi devenus des donneurs d'ordre
qui liste les actions moyennement
finances que si groupuscules sont
obligés de réaliser s'ils veulent avoir
des moyens financiers
les actions qui semblent porter sur des
fondamentaux de la cause anti chasse qui
se résume à transfigurer la vérité des
images et des mots j'en reviens de loin
ce qui est fait dans le ton le site des
ajouts un chasseur à détruire et brûler
les infrastructures cynégétique et bien
d'autres choses encore tout cela
mesdames et messieurs fait froid dans le
dos et met en lumière les dérives de ce
soi-disant camp du bien de ces grandes
associations à la plus petite cellule
dormante qui aujourd'hui semble
fonctionner selon des méthodes mafieuses
et menacent dorénavant l'intégrité
physique des gens qui ne partagent pas
leurs idées de leurs idéologies je sais
de quoi je parle pourquoi j'évoque ces
points en conclusion notre position car
ils font partie de ce harcèlement
sécuritaire de l'opinion publique par
des propos et des écrits totalement
déformés mensonge est porteur de haine
et de violence dessinée parfois
malheureusement aux plus jeunes d'entre
vous comme je viens de le décrire madame
la présidente
dans les jours qui viennent je porterai
donc sur votre petit 6-3 première
pétition très à la mode qui illustre
parfaitement la conclusion de mes propos
j'en appellerai d'ailleurs aux chasseurs
comme aux autres usagers de la nature
qui sont en droit de demander que ces
sujets soient traités avec le même
sérieux qui est le vôtre dans cet audit
de la sécurité à la chasse avec
l'ensemble de mes collègues présidents
et avec toutes nos partenaires usagers
comme nous de la nature nous
continuerons de travailler avec
acharnement et motivation pour continuer
de faire baisser encore et toujours le
nombre des accidents liés à la chasse je
vous remercie de m'avoir écouté
[Musique]